the whistles go whoa hey how's it going
team Coco this is me blake anderson and
i would like to show you some of my very
very very very favorite videos from
youtube
nearly every muffler shop in oakland is
installing whistler tips my first video
is a classic we're talking about
bubb-rubb and lil sis come on you
remember whoa whoa the whistle tip video
is called a whistle tip and it's welded
inside a car's muffler to make the car
screeching lee lao for nearly a mile
tell me about the whistles the whistles
go whoo
bubb-rubb guy is a Bay Area Legend
Raiders head to toe
it's a wool wool everybody in the
neighborhood was kind of like freaking
out driving me nuts I work at home I
can't concentrate I Bubb rubb is like
what's the big deal
we're just out here styling some
neighbors were saying way too loud
that's only in the morning he calls me
up cooking breath as the Sun biling
yourself
that's like alarm clock it's like an
alarm clock whoa
bubb-rubb
and little sis were proud to show it off
some Oakland residents will complain
about the noisemakers Tuesday night at
the City Council meeting my next video
another classic it's a running theme
with my videos because I only watch
classic things mr. Luger mr. Luger this
is a little bit of a blooper from the
pro wrestler Lex Luger what kind of
disgusting despicable lack of respect is
that Billy what's his name show
absolutely one of my favorites because
Lex Luger basically is just completely
botching this interview and the
frustration pouring out of him is just
classic comedy look at a match for the
total package Lex Luger SuperBrawl super
scary what is it I know it's called what
does it call SuperBrawl Saturday Super
Ball Saturday he tries taking this shirt
off he's like God
it's t-shirt tight Billy oh man what's
the last line he says oh I'm pissed now
look at me all the total package I will
rip it apart I'm pissed now I basically
am just quoting them video three very
very special and dear to my heart this
is the peer pressure Dance Crew Pretty
Ricky late-night special wow you are in
for it cuz this dance crew has some
moves like you've never seen
[Music]
I can kind of demonstrate them for you
it's a lot of this there's no nudity but
there is some air humping
enjoy all right shifting gears a little
bit we're stepping out of comedy and
just going straight into epic
storytelling a snake's eyes aren't very
good but they can detect a movement so
if the hatchling keeps its nerve it may
just avoid detection the story of this
little iguana dude escaping this huge
pack of snakes it's just mind-blowing
it's like the greatest story it's the
best movie I've seen in 10 years I hope
it's not CGI I don't think I think it's
actual truth what it
and it's completely real it's completely
nature planet Earth what a special place
we live on in what a special earth is so
nice a near miraculous escape all right
this last video is a little something
for all the little Stoney baloney is out
there why don't you go ahead and type in
malice in Wonderland this is an adult
animation it starts off with a lot of
vaginal art but once you get through
that it gets pretty frickin trippy dude
[Music]
it's like a reinterpretation of Alice in
Wonderland but man they just don't make
cartoons like this anymore
mostly with lots of vaginal art I'm like
trying to avoid saying the word vagina
but something tells me that vaginal art
sounds force it does doesn't it
sorry look at three hey thanks for
watching I just hope you watch all five
of my videos over and over and over
again until they're burnt into your
brains like they are in mine
satisfaction